you
yeah so thank you for coming it's really
excited to be here it's a little bit
dangerous to let me talk about particle
physics because once I get going I have
to really work to stop but I know where
the time is of my lap topic curitiba the
best inch waist time so today what I'm
going to do is before I launch into some
of the physics I'm going to tell you why
I'm up here doing the physics or if
you're able to talk about the physics
we're going to go into what particle
physics is now just to get a sense of it
how many of you can you raise your hand
if you have a definition for particle
physics if you think you would know what
it is particle physics there's a couple
people okay so we're going to do a
little bit of work to help define what
particle physics is I'll tell you about
this incredible machine the Large Hadron
Collider that lets us do a teacher for
doing and then the Atlas experiment and
I have some really great pictures I
think about starting here so when I
first thought about things which
actually was pretty early I thinking
life I assumed that there was kind of a
plan there is a straight line if you
moved from one thing to the next thing
so a lot of you are in this middle
school category here and then you know
it's a next one to do you know even a
high school they need to go to college
and then if you decide you want my
building go on in academia and become a
professor or a faculty member you know
when you go to graduate school you don't
post off do in fact Phoenix and you know
you're you're always dine here it's very
straightforward they didn't really take
that path at all of course I'm not
Einstein it turns out i'm in this
category right here still but i want to
talk to a little bit about how things
went from
I grew up in a town of 500 people in
Vermont it was like I don't know have
anything though Norman Rockwell
paintings that might not be familiar to
you but that's basically what it was
like my dad was the pastor of this
methodist church in the middle of the
town and everybody knew everybody's
secrets when I was in eighth grade we
moved to morrisville Demond which had
2,000 people and a movie theater and a
restaurant a gas station all right I
felt like I had seriously arrived in
high school I was pretty much a
humanities person meaning I love to read
I love to write I was really into
debates and arguing like not meeting
i'll be a lawyer and one of my teachers
said you know in high school Taylor 11th
grade really should consider becoming a
research scientist and it really came
out of left field I don't know what do
you think of when you think of a
research scientist at this point you're
like what do you think of what's the
picture that comes to your mind first
yeah
somebody who does a lot of research
excellent and what does that look like I
mean anybody have an image of that I can
tell you what my image was not this
excited was this people looking at test
tubes different colors and maybe they
seemed happy but in my mind they were in
a basement they were definitely wearing
lab coats and I just had no idea why
they would look happy looking at test
tubes I mean when I thought research
scientist I thought that just sounds
terrible what's that is the sound
interesting i have no idea what that
kind of work we look like and I really
wanted to study the Constitution I
really thought this was good at arguing
and I thought that was the path I was
headed into and then I took physics a
lot of you haven't taken physics only go
to you're taking physics have little
bits okay some of the people who are no
longer available it turns out i have
been walking around for like 17 years
and i've noticed I've been paying
attention I've been paying serious
attention to the world around me and I
have gotten almost all of it wrong it
was shocking to me to learn that I had
such the wrong picture of how nature it
really is and what the laws of physics
really are and you know maybe that's the
depressing realization but for me it was
really fascinating i just want to give
you one example that stuck in my mind
because it is growing there's an example
with like you have a BB gun and a baby i
come from the town of 500 so we go to BB
guns what I grew up so if you are on a
flat surface you're on a plane
oh very flat and you can't none of this
even if you drop the BB it's fire the
gun at the same time when you have a VD
that's going out it turns out that those
two TVs hit the ground at the same time
now I don't know what that's shocking to
you or not but I thought the world's
fired from the gun has some moment and
it has something that keeps it in the
air longer than the one that just hits
and drops the ground does anybody have
that intuition like I did refer none of
your presence anyway I have intuition
that was totally wrong and the more you
learn about physics really when I got to
follow mechanics and I will learn how
crazy the world really in spurts amazing
anyone who's taken while they can expend
sleep at night right I learned more and
more how wrong it was and how amazing
universe really is so I was totally
hooked on it wasn't my best subject when
I started into it that I was really
hooked by the time I got to college I
had a lot of fun i was on the crew team
and I was a major in physics and I had
an opportunity I was a work-study
student got to work 10 hours a week in a
lab of and professor Melissa Franklin's
at particle physics in harvard she's no
cheering in the physics department was
hiring and so and she has to work in her
lab and I got to work on the CD after a
changeup and when I started learning
about the detectors in front of physics
I got I totally was addicted to it i'm
going to show you a couple of pictures
today that i think are amazing and tell
you about the detector that I work on
out is actually six stories high it's
really incredible this is a drip chamber
that has over 10,000 wires in it and
it's something that lets us everybody
had a chance to see the cloud chamber
out there that that cloud that forms
that lets you actually see evidence of
articles traveling through it the drift
chamber is a different way that you can
have access to particles traveling
through me this is the detector that
lets us trace the path particles that
have charged and it's just gorgeous and
the entire machine at the colliders
tetra Fermilab outside of Chicago was
just gorgeous the electronics that were
involved and when I started to learn
about how the machines worked and I'm
going to go into it a little bit I
realized that some of its common sense
you know it's accessible with its really
it's exciting to dive into that system
of the electronics when i get to talking
about the Atlas detector I'll give you
some statistics that just for my mind so
I was hooked to a particle physics as an
undergraduate um not that we've defined
it yet but I was leaving soon and went
to graduate school University of
Rochester and did my thesis on GM
experiment where I had started working
as an undergraduate and now it's time
for confessions I'm being taped but I'm
just going to go forth and tell you
anyway at the end of graduate school I
was destroyed absolutely destroyed I had
a great experience I learned a ton I was
exhausted and I was passionate about
teaching I was at a point where I
thought I I just don't know if I'm
capable of doing the search I don't know
if I think you could keep doing this
sometimes in life you find yourself in
that position where you've worked you've
worked and you're just exhausted so what
I did was not rational I went to a place
where I was really teaching four or five
courses a year and four five courses a
semester and the only physics teacher in
college so I got myself be much much
more exhausted but um had a chance to
teach them awful lot of physics at
roberts wesleyan college of fantastic
place and realized remember how much I
six and realize how much I missed the
research in spite of how much i love the
teaching i wanted both the apart my life
okay so i got a job as a post post doc
which I was for the last one I'm talking
about and i moved to geneva switzerland
where both of my children were born is
just one of my children Jonah was born
as a postdoc and I now have two kids I
came back to the US in july two thousand
nine Jonah and Alena were both born in
Switzerland and Jonah is actually at
this very moment getting his haircut so
this is an appropriate picture industry
okay so i had two kids my husband is a
research scientist here at yale and i
came back to the US and continued with
particle physics now as a professor mrs.
impresarios so that's that's me and why
I'm here I hope a little bit helpful so
now part of a business that's let's see
what we can do a couple people raise
their hand can anybody help me out in
terms of a definition functions yeah
particle physics it's really just the
study of all physics I like that all
phases of apartments like different
types of particles bosons sports and
then there are different branches of the
study of horrible things excellent
mainly particle physics is the study
apart excellent yes a study of particles
and you should make sure the particles
bosons works together may not have heard
of those particles anybody have anything
they want to add to that yeah please how
about that nun jus we're talking was
also
wait ok particles and and particles
behave in this way how do we handle that
money let me tell you that they're
extremely ambitious in particle physics
we pretty much would like to describe
everything if you want to talk about
things in terms of ways that's fine with
us we have a particle description we can
use that also that's also valid so let
me tell you how we would phrase these
questions all right certainly all of
these particles which which matter in
the universe who are studying everything
about them and you know what they all
are we want to know one of the
fundamental forces how can we describe
them and this is interesting right we
don't just want to describe them we want
to describe them in the cleanest
simplest way possible and we think that
if we can describe them in the cleanest
simplest way that shows the best level
of understanding that we could manage
for them we want to avoid the content of
the universe and how is it matter
interact through the courses that's a
lot of questions I don't know if any of
them makes sense but I can break it down
from you know how as a particle
physicist my thing before I keep going
in this direction I want to ask you why
would you care about the answer to any
of these questions because I would like
you to care for at least the next you
know 30 minutes or so
number anybody know why why am I so
excited up here not the caffeine I've
had this morning why do we care about
yeah good so mystery of the universe
like trying to find out everything okay
trying to find out everything that's
just an interesting thing to do isn't it
do you think people what they're trying
to do that for a long time ever since
the first people looked up with the
Stars I figure out where are we who are
we how does everything work here these
are interesting questions it seems to be
something innately human about
technically these questions anything
else or is that enough to beat the storm
two three minutes yeah gravity yes
gravity everybody experiences it you
know it exists how does it work it's
important for us to understand things
that we have to deal with in life right
definitely okay thanks hopefully that
will carry us to the next 30 minutes
because i'm going to show you a couple
of pictures that might not be familiar
okay inside of particle physics the
things that we know is that we've
categorized and understand but it could
describe within the standard model and
we break up all these particles of
different categories we have some point
we have some leptons and we have some
forces I'm not going to spend a lot of
time talking about these individual
particles very much sorry but I do want
to talk about the forces just really
quickly we believe that there are four
forces in nature all right
electromagnetic weak strong and gravity
let's start with the top one when you
hear the word electromagnetic kick
anybody
lightness okay electricity refrigerator
magnets I think you would believe me if
I told you that electrode
electromagnetic forces are real okay
that's an actual force we're there what
a weak force have you heard of the week
for support yes sir do you know what it
is to define I mean it's excellent
that's exactly how I define it okay it's
not a push or pull force that's
fantastic actually can I steal that I'm
going to steal that for the future and
it's on video staking ittle bit nervous
right it's not a push or force it's a
decaying force radioactive decays you've
heard of radioactivity that's that's
because of the weak force now the strong
force has anyone heard of the strong
force unbelievable I'm moving cold
that's an excellent okay so I have
everything my people think you've heard
of the Star Force listen when I took
chemistry in high school which some of
you are going to do at some point maybe
you've actually seen how part of protons
before you're going to learn about an
atom at some point in your life
community learn had all of you learned
that things that are positively charged
negatively charged are attracted to each
other and things that have the same
charge don't want to hang out
each other you have okay excellent so
that's a yes you've heard of this all
right so we're starting from that point
you're then going to learn that inside
the atom all of the protons that are
positively charged are cramped in really
close to each other in the middle of a
nucleus and when I learned that
information on confessing to you right
now I wrote it down in my notebook and
didn't worry about it until a couple of
years by their phone and wait a second
why are these things are all positively
charged really do not want to hang out
next to each other cramped into this
tiny area of the people used it really
doesn't make any sense you can think
about it gravity isn't strong enough to
keep them all fall together it takes
something very strong to pull these
things together and sometimes you get
lucky enough so that the language that
you use which actually makes sense the
strong force is a strong force and the
mediator the carrier of the strong
forces made to the gluon isn't that
awesome in that move not only keeps the
protons together inside the atom it
keeps the courts that are inside the
proton together okay gravity gravity
isn't actually in the standard model of
physics what that means technically is
that we have not incorporated a quantum
theory of gravity we don't have a field
theory of gravity okay bummer sectors
madera see I mean gravity all of us know
about it been around for a while what's
our excuse why am i standing proudly in
front of them saying this let me do just
an experiment with you how how strong is
the gravitational force between my two
hands when you have our hands like this
next to each other we know that gravity
is an attractive force masses or
for each other or I and pull toward the
earth because of gravity right but I
don't even feel that force between my
two hands can you feel the gravitational
force if you put your two hands
Association I don't even feel any
attractive portion or right but you're
going to learn out at some point in life
well actually right now turns out your
hands are mostly made out of space but
you can't pass them through each other
it's the force of electricity and
magnetism that case you from pushing
your hands with each other's even though
it turns out that that the matter inside
of your hands means it's concentrated in
ways they're mostly space the force of
electricity and magnetism is incredibly
strong compared to the gravitational
force alright so there's our excuse it's
the incredibly weak gravity as compared
these other forces and robotic we're
walking right and since we're debating
caveats here it turns out that about
ninety six percent of the universe isn't
part of the standard model we have dark
energy Dark Matter things I'd love to
talk about more so if you're thinking of
going into this field don't worry
there's plenty to do we have a lot of
work to do okay but how do I know that
any of these particles exist i showed
you a list of products and supports
leptons and the board and round it goes
on how do I know that amuses exist do
you have evidence for particles existing
would you believe this stuff will be
here I hope you're taking my word for
some extent did anybody see the cloud
chamber your dip so you saw evidence of
traps of particles or something there
right what's up okay i want to tell you
just about a little bit of the history
of particle physics so that you have
some so grounding pair when we go into
talking about present-day accelerators
scientists have a reputation for really
doing crazy things it's proud reputation
for doing crazy things the back end in
the early 1900's people knew that there
was radioactivity and the earth was the
source of radioactivity okay we know
that now as well there's three do to be
around out of you guys have radar
measurements in basements that you're
aware of any way people are doing
experiments they want to understand what
this is rigo to see how does it work how
strong is it so they had detectors that
could measure radioactivity and they
were bold and they said okay if I climb
up to the top of a mountain I'm further
away from the mass of the earth so the
amount of radioactivity value measure
should go down and then they weren't
satisfied by finding the top of mountain
they actually went up with their
detectors in balloons okay they carry
their detectors in balloons with them to
try to see how that day you actually
changes as they got further away from
the surface of the earth at in 1912
Victor has got up to 5,000 meters in a
balloon that's that's very far up there
and he realized shockingly he was going
up in the balloon the level of
radioactivity was going down as he got
further away from the surface of the
earth and then all of a sudden the level
of
activities starting to go and as they
got further up he saw that it continued
to climb and that was the discovery that
we also have braided out to be coming at
us from the universe okay that was the
discovery of cosmic rays not only do we
have a source of radioactivity linear as
you get further away from the earth and
that the idea there was the atmosphere
is blocking a lot of that we invented be
coming in from outside and she get
further up and have less that was here
between you and the universe you start
to send some of that radioactivity and
in 1938 PR oj put detectors on the tops
of mountains that were separated by some
distance and he learned that not only
are is the arena actually coming at us
from the from the universe you know just
punch single particles coming down but
there were actually showers of particles
and this is a nice graphic that
describes what happens is you have a
high-energy parkin coming in the
universe there showering apartments a
lot of the activity that you were seeing
in the cloud chamber that wasn't near
that source was because of cosmic rays
we have cosmic rays passing when I was
in graduate school well so now we still
send balloons up in particle physics to
try to learn more about these cosmic
rays and maybe what much higher don't
have people anymore when I was in
graduate school I was tempted a little
bit to change experiments to the pierre
oj collaboration they have a grid of
detectors that are in spread out over a
very large distance it turns out they're
over they have been almost two thousands
of these tank detectors over 3,000
script longers or argentina i went to a
talk by a peerage a scientist you know
what they talked about cows one of their
biggest problems in their experiments
were animals wandering over to the
experiments in action
messing things up so I thought wow that
is just so cool you re doing particle
physics and you're talking about cows
right now and you know they had to go
and learn about the different animals
and and how to kind of protect their
animals and not interfere with Stephanie
and it's very funny ok that was just an
aside there we have what i do i work in
is actually using accelerators it's nice
that nature gives us the source of
cosmic rays do we can learn about these
elementary particles you know coming at
us from the sky it's also nice to have
some control over them inspire partners
on each other and be able to to measure
the coke the result of those collisions
of her enormous progress but we haven't
stopped being crazy incredible physics
look at this picture of the Katrina
experiment coming through a town in
Germany there were they were talking
about the clearance on either side of
those houses at the level of millimeters
ok this detector was moving very slowly
through this town and in order to get it
to its final location this is part of
not be smarter than i'm on the Atlas
detector actually crossing the street in
in Switzerland background um this is a
pretty cool picture can you see that
picture well alright well if you go to
graduate school in physics you can think
back to this moment or actually graduate
school or anything actually anything in
life you can think that to this moment
when you're doing something that may see
so this is a giant tank that's being
filled with water and there are
photomultiplier tubes that help you in
the detection of neutrinos is what
they're trying to gather there watching
the interaction in this giant tank of
water what's happening are these little
people in the boat are very slowly being
raised up as the tank is they filled and
they're going around about cleaning all
the photomultiplier tubes which I think
probably was really awesome for a while
but after a while you know that's a lot
of
before I launch into the large hadron
collider you know this is the end my
last introduction particle physics slide
I think it's important the reason that
we do this science is because we're
really excited to learn more about
nature it doesn't really have a direct
practical application we're not trying
to build anything out particles that are
colliding but there are a lot of
positive benefits that come out for
society because of the research I think
it's really important to to at least
mention that the National Science
Foundation tells us that about point
four percent of our GDP goes towards
basic research and it's helpful to know
there are outcomes of Cyclone from
changing textbooks which i think is
fantastic and you never know your
discoveries where where that new
information will lead you but there's an
awful lot that accelerators are already
doing the force in society okay so two
more things that I'd like to do this
morning i haven't mentioned the Higgs
boson yet so we're going to go there and
that's really motivated by thinking
about the large hadron collider and the
Large Hadron Collider this is the
machine that creates coalition's that I
study alone many of my friends in the
absence of stir the Large Hadron
Collider so let's think a little bit
about how it works it's whatever dinners
for the ground the alps from one side to
show up on the other side and the
protons they're circling around here
spend most of their time in frames
really
that time in Switzerland crosses over
into Switzerland even though the third
sighting is actually built its with the
goal of the Large Hadron Collider is to
bring protons to high energy and I
describe myself as a particle physicist
or high energy physicist why do you
think about studying elementary
particles do I need to be at high energy
why am i interested in high-energy
anybody have any ideas yeah
okay export point when you going up so I
he was mentioning of the hierarchy I
mentioned that the cosmic rays that come
in are at high energy and it's not just
one particle that comes in when it
starts to interact with the atmosphere
there's a lot of energy and agrees to
cascade of particles and if you pointed
out that there you have a lot that you
can study here that's certainly a
fundamental reason that we would go to
high energy because you have all of this
energy available that can create a lot
of different particles and thank you
that was perfect right into my e equals
MC squared people participation cooking
equals experiences and aunt relativistic
version which have excellent it turns
out that energy on this side of the
equation can be thought of as the
potential equivalents for producing mass
on this I provision this see here stands
the speed of light okay so you have
energy on one side you have mass or the
other side if I have a lot of energy I
can create a lot of mass and the
particles that I weren't studying a lot
of them have a lot of maths turns out
the Higgs boson has mass and if I want
to create the Higgs boson I have to have
enough energy that I put in in order to
get an excel so that's really important
he talked about that strong force that
holds the proton together or hold
bunches of protons together in order to
break those bonds inside protons between
port the forks any any anything where
the strong force is working it takes a
lot of energy in order to break those
bonds okay so that's another reason that
everyone behind regime and the other
reason to go to high energy is we're in
the game of discovery and when you climb
up to higher energy it's like climbing
up a barrel
looking around you can see more from up
there right we talked about it in terms
of covering more phase space going to
high energy allows us to discover new
things in terms of how we get to high
energy we try to increase the kinetic
energy the particle so is that the
energy of motion but I think about this
I like to think about gravity even
surrounding something I understand
pretty well if I drop a pettings from
right here it's going to get faster the
longer it stays falling right if I drop
it from the top of a building it's going
to be following for a long retirement is
going to pick up speed you're keeping an
object moving in a gravitational field
the longer you keep an object moving
under the influence of gravity without
stopping it faster and cats what we do
is we put particles and electric fields
charged particles and electric fields
and keep them there for a long time we
have two different kinds of accelerators
that give us these electric fields you
have the linear accelerators where it's
a straight shot boom send a particle
heading out in that direction I mean
smashing something at the end or if
you're really excited had to the nearest
others who firing the particles at each
other he could even more entertainment
center or you can have circular
accelerators which is what the LHC is so
why would you why linear versus circular
if you're making that decision you're
planning the metric celery yeah okay
you're thinking about cost his best it
depends on how you design it but that's
a huge reason that you care one way or
the other so yeah if you have a circular
accelerator you not only have to speed
the thing up but you have to steer it
right and steering it needs magnets and
so depending on how to design things
circular accelerators keen sense
the magnets for expensive that's a great
for the benefit of a circular
accelerator is it's like you cheated you
keep the thing steering around and it
keeps staying in the field keeps staying
in the electric field against pastor and
faster and faster nasty right as opposed
to just having one shot or flies by and
you've got to do that acceleration in
this piece okay so yes a couple of
numbers we accelerate protons to point b
9 9 9 9 9 9 9 9 at the right times you
can count on the screen times the speed
of light he sends not be swinging very
close to the city plane it's 27
kilometers around 27 kilometers around
have any sense of how big that is has
anyone been to the grid I hadn't until I
was you see you seen pictures here's a
picture of the Grand Canyon you know
that it's big right this is me and my
husband on our way to my postdoc at
favor before I headed out to to stirring
five o'clock in the morning if you go
with the green cave seriously it gets
really crowded at the grave
very early gorgeous awesome sunrise
sunrise it's okay so this doesn't rain
came in here's a mock of the Grand
Canyon the LHC circumference I've drawn
our beer so that you can sleep it's the
scale of the Grand Canyon and if you
hadn't been that may not sound babe but
if you have them it is me I thought
about comparing the LHC devotions I
thought about comparing it to sky I
thought about you know anything that's
that big I can't really keep my head
around it but the Grand Canyon is a big
thing you can kind of keep your head
around and the LHC is about that big
buried underground the thing about the
election in the Higgs is we have to be
able just a slight problem understand
the bond with particle physics and that
is all of these particles mathematically
without any intervention should be
moving at speed of light the speed of
light its speed limit that we know about
writing photons with the line carrying
argument moving at the speed of light
the question that we have in particle
physics games why is it that we all can
exist right here why are all particles
not moving at the speed of light it
turns out particles have this quantity
that we call nass they have proper
components and the fact that mask keeps
them from moving at the speed of light
and the LHC was built in a way that
would let us either find or rule out one
idea for giving particles Maps the Higgs
boson particle that gives us an
explanation for how things get gas and I
promise I'm not going to spend a lot of
time I love this plot very much that I
ever said a lot of you this is not an
awful lot but those of you who have had
some background this
sure right here is absolutely the
motivation for the LHC it contains on it
we're going to a particle we don't know
like announces that part that is so it
contains on it possible masses of this
axis of the particle at the app and this
is a picture before we turn down the LHC
this yellow stuff that's blocked out
shows you where other experiments would
already look for it and not seen it and
this point right here tells you where
it's predicted to be alright so the
picture before we turn on the LHC is we
have a prediction of the massive village
of updates right here it's already been
looked forward of our experiments and
not found there and the LHC is going to
let us cover this area right here right
that was the motivation for the LA sure
there are many many many other physics
projects going on at the LHC a lot of
them that my group involved in the case
with a central motivator and just to
convince you that this is something
that's exciting to a lot of us this is a
fissure in the atmosphere women 2009.com
of the first collision event that was
captured on the screens in the control
room you actually can go to the control
room webcam and look at any time as you
just how excited people are compared to
this it's updated every 30 seconds or so
but some of us get really excited about
electrons so
spells of course so that's the Large
Hadron Collider it's a circular
accelerator it smashes protons together
at a couple of different points and one
of the points where it smashes protons
is the Atlas detector the goal of a
detector is to completely surround the
collision with with information with
with technology that gives you
information about what happened inside
of that collision and I'll talk about
that a little bit more with this picture
ok so here it is the Atlas experiment
this is to make everyone feel better
about acronyms this is torture and it
gets if you ever designing the group
pain don't worry about where you pull
the letters from
kind of have it added inside your Apple
right feel free somebody's been worse
about it than you will ever be able to
be but this is a picture you get protons
living in and they're colliding at the
center of the detector here and the
Atlas detector is built around that
collision point and when you have the
protons collide it turns out whatever
the picture that resolve the cosmic rays
come with all through the equivalence of
particles that come out of the collision
of the part of parts of the protein
point at the center one of the things I
love about particle physics is how
international it is there are 3,000
people are most experiment my view of
the research scientist sitting alone in
the basement with no windows was so far
off in terms of what I actually do so I
do spend some time by myself in front of
my computer I'm thinking and getting
work done i'm also working with 3,000 of
my best friends from all over the world
south africa is also joined the office
experiment who's there that's a little
bit outdated it turns out it's really
hard to have a meeting with all these
people even on the gold a lot of times
i'm up at three o'clock in the morning
just last week comes up at three in
order to sign in and you know Australia
Japan it's yeah
so here it is here's Atlas 40 years
working certainty this is kind of a
shell the muon detectors in Detroit
manacles I see this person came in here
he adds detector waste as much as the
Eiffel Tower you seen pictures of the
Eiffel Tower it's six stories high it's
really complicated see the people show
you the scale of the pub how big it is
been here to those people you can't go
down and visit it now because it's been
running first of all you don't want to
be near where the collisions are
happening it's hundred meters
underground portion of the breezies
there's also some radioactivity that
builds up that takes a while for things
to cool down before you go back in and
and can check it out probably this
summer we have shut down coming up soon
than people should go down and see if
you happen to be a switch weren't going
next week but I know not everybody has a
reason to travel there are different
kinds of detectors we have what we call
tracking detectors on the inside however
there are lots of different technologies
I would have flash up some pictures
because as I told you this was really
the thing when I started working hard
for physics that totally pulling in
seeing how these detectors work and you
see the pictures of these you know the
light coming out when these fibers
there's just so much cool physics that's
in this I actually work on the part of
the experiment that's called the trigger
we have equity 20 50 seconds 40 million
times a second there are bunches that
came to line at the center of the
detector you can only keep information
about 200 of them so you have to decide
what's interesting I am on shift in
well I'm very pregnant almost joined
here so it was too during 2008 I was on
shift in Switzerland living in
Switzerland right I was there for four
years and my family was in the US and so
I used to call them as much as I could
over the computer but I can mail them a
couple of weeks before this picture was
taken hey guys I'm community control
room I'm gonna be art [ __ ] and there's a
webcam moving this website and you can
check it out you can see me on shift
three weeks later I got an email from my
younger brother Micah well names video
the subject of the email was hungry and
if you zoom in you can see my hand kinda
like this i don't have this zoom in for
mayor because my cheeks are out to like
here another great thing about particle
physics is we don't work with materials
when you can't eat laughs what I could
do if I could when I was doing my work
because it's working on that so yeah my
cheeks are like out to here is be really
careful what information you send to her
family but it was nice to be able to
stay here I'll in the control room
getting ready for the run this is really
we have thousands of computers set up to
help us make decisions about what kinds
of events are interesting and just to
show you some of the things that we're
looking for we're looking at your black
hole events were looking for caves
events you can ask yourself how do you
know that you've actually seen any
looking for we make nice pretty pictures
and also do really detailed analyses of
you know what if we have created a black
hole in the middle of our experiment
which we hope we're doing this is the
output that you would get from the
detector this is the kind of information
always particles streaming out if you
can track and see in the detector in
this way so if we see something a
signature that resembles this that we
can pick out from other other pictures
when you get out you would have evidence
for a black woman and this is a picture
that shows you what a Higgs event it
simulated would look like one when
possible takes events use some of the
particles that are particularly easy for
us to pick out in a detector they're
called the left on the electron and the
new on you BTW here I let us pick out in
this mess to see this mess that's
another picture way to look at the
opposite Ector you're looking at it head
on and see Molly Energy deposits that
are being divided particles coming in
you have to pick out something that's
pretty that stand out all of that nest
and we use the physics that we know in
the standard model to help us do that on
july 4th a couple months ago there was
the announcement from two of the
experiments really likes her with
someone else of the discovery of a new
particle okay so here we have a viola
spokesperson line through and enjoy
inconel is actually american assistant
California who's a spokesperson Gilbert
staring at that announcement of the
discovery
is a picture of very tired PL
undergraduates we had Katie Maddie Ariel
catherine was a Jerry re they camped out
the night for a bit like living in
France not going far away from you know
where the headquarters were in finding
the Switzerland and they rode their
bikes in like 11 of pocket knife aired
out in front of the doors of the the
radio announcer was going to be in turn
about Obama concert you know really want
to get in you get there really early and
there was a lot of people that were
camped out they had this fight for their
position in line and that was even a
fire alarm that went off at my three
o'clock in the morning and you know all
of these these obstacles in brookings so
they're looking very tired right now but
they had a lot of energy was expended
getting into it this is reporting them
but basically the idea is at this point
in the research stuck with me well at
this point in our research we have a
particle that we've discovered we picked
it out because of the signature the way
it looks in the detector it's looking an
awful lot like the Higgs boson but we're
not ready I'm not ready to say it's
definitely they expose okay there's more
work than need to do there's no it's not
something that looks like we don't want
to be wrong here we don't have a lot of
LHC's in order to have a lot of
opportunities to get this right but it
looks like we may have an answer for why
it is that all these particles aren't
moving at the speed of life for what is
slowing these particles down what is
giving us this idea
mass beyond the heads I think the LHC
the Large Hadron Collider at CERN it
really can revolutionize what we know
about physics because the Higgs is not
the only thing we're after by studying
these fundamental particles and go to
higher energies you think I'm going to
be able to well i think i'm going to be
able to learn a lot about physics we
hope you can but even if they're giving
a lot out that is discovered have the
latest even though we've already raised
in snow I'll be festive like we may have
this Higgs boson this new model and
thank you very much i know this stuff
wasn't all easy i really appreciate your
attention
you